it was mental but it made perfect sense
in Colin Farrell's new dark comedy the
lobster he plays David a recently single
man who must find love in 45 days or
else he'll be turned into an animal
now have you thought of what animal
you'd like to be if you end up alone yes
a lobster the Irish actor revealed to ET
how he put on over 45 pounds for the
role putting on weight for a role is
that like a dream for an actor or were
you kind of dreading for about two days
yeah perfect days I was wondering how is
he doing it how's he doing it so fast
and then he's like ha just eat
haagen-dazs you know or ice cream or
whatever and I was like but how can you
eat that much ice cream in a day without
getting a freeze headache and without
missing a beat like oh just just warming
up and just drink it's in the microwave
you were literally drinking liquid
haagen-dazs morning noon and night it
was a better drinker than in these ER
and so I just applied that group how did
you drop the weight so quickly I don't
the weight so quickly just by a me
starving and I'm working out kinda just
that way yeah it's just yet so I've just
eat loads and sit on your arse like me
sister asked me when we were in the
hotel or shooting a film and missus
should say going for walk around the
grounds of the hotel and I'd say no can
do this when you come back as you could
give me a piggy back to my bedroom